- This next section,
we're gonna be focused
on modern SOF strategy.
Really, we're gonna
build off the framework
that DASD Logan presented
during our keynote.
Additionally, we're
gonna have Peter Bergen,
who is a senior CNN News analyst,
to moderate the presentation
for our four panelists.
We're gonna have about 50 minutes for them
to engage in conversation.
Additionally, we'll have
about 15, 20 minutes of Q&A.
Again, please think about some questions.
We want this to be interactive.
We want some provocative thoughts,
some ideas to flow.
So think about that as Peter
moderates this conversation.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Mike.
Also, we have an all-star panel.
Directly to my left is Colonel Jewell,
who's the director
of the Adaptive Innovative
Statecraft Unit in
at JSOU multiple combat tours in Iraq.
Next to Colonel Jewell
is Colonel Hooker who,
amongst other things,
was senior director for Europe and Russia
at the NSC between 2017 and 2018.
Kind of an interesting
time to be doing that.
And also was the Teddy
Roosevelt chair at NDU.
He's now a senior fellow
at the Atlantic Council.
Next to him is Ben Milligan,
who was on SEAL Team 4 and 5.
He just wrote this book,
"By Water Beneath the Walls:
The Rise of the Navy SEALs".
I read 150 pages of of it last night.
I could not put it down.
It is so good.
Took him seven years to write.
And next to him is Colonel Collins,
who is the executive director
of the Viola Foundation,
the editor of "Routledge
handbook of U.S. Counterterrorism
and Irregular Warfare",
which is absolutely massive
and authoritative book,
which was done in the
memory of Mike Sheehan
who was ASD-SOLIC.
And probably some of
you now remember Mike,
he is also the co-author of
"Understanding Urban Warfare",
which I think is gonna be a
useful discussion point here.
And he used
to direct the Counterterrorism
Center at West Point.
So I'm just gonna start
with Colonel Hooker,
if you don't mind,
because you wrote
what I thought was a
rather provocative piece,
which you can describe perhaps
and give us the, I would say,
a blistering critique
of Special Operations
as they are presently constructed.
So go ahead.
- Well, okay.
Thanks for that.
I guess still kind of
wondering why I was invited
to this conference.
I wanna lead off
by saying what I said in
my JFQ article up front,
which is that, undeniably,
special operating forces have a key role
to play in national security.
Undeniably, special operating
forces have a key role
to play in national security.
I wanna put that up front.
But I hope to inject some balance
into the conversation today.
And I hope I don't trigger
anybody in the room,
but maybe that wouldn't be
such a bad thing after all.
I'm gonna give you a perspective
from outside the SOF community,
from the conventional community,
but also I think from the
policymaking point of view,
which is informed by, I guess,
my three tours on the
National Security Council.
So let's talk a little bit
about some of the trends
in the SOF community really since 9/11.
So the first is a real explosion in size.
So SOF doubled in size from
9/11 to the present day.
How did it do that?
The 4th Battalion was
added to each SF group.
Along with a special troops battalion,
military intelligence battalion added
to the 75th Ranger Regiment,
which also added to 4th Rifle Company
and his support company in each battalion
and on and on and on.
I've got a document here that's put out
by the Assistant Secretary of Defense
for Manpower and Reserve Affairs,
which I found really interesting
at doing the research for the article.
So I was kind of dumbfounded to read
that where the joint staff
has 2,390 folks assigned,
and CENTCOM has 1,466.
This was in 2020.
USSOCOM had 6,194.
Well, now when you push this forward
to the most current document,
which is an estimate of F-22,
the numbers are about the
same for the joint staff,
for the other combatant commands.
SOCOM comes in at 73,923,
which I think is the entire community.
So why that methodology
is applied to this number
into no one else?
I'm not sure,
but there is an answer
out there somewhere.
It might be to obscure the
size of the SOCOM staff.
It's not clear to me why
the SOCOM staff needs
to be exponentially larger
than everybody else,
but maybe somebody in the room
can help me out with that.
So a big explosion in size.
So the obvious kind of
question to that is,
how do you maintain the
quality of the force
when you've doubled in size?
So, we'll get into that a little bit later
in my presentation, I think.
Dazi told us that SOF forces,
when compared to everyone else,
are not putting words in your mouth.
They're cheap,
2% or whatever, whatever.
Well, they're pretty expensive actually
because a lot of the costs
are hidden in service budget.
So manpower costs, for example, is one,
but many acquisition costs as well.
Even so, SOCOM's budget requests
for the current year was larger
than the entire defense budget of Poland,
which is NATO's largest
and strongest military,
at least until Ukraine gets in,
which hopefully won't be too much longer.
So that's an interesting statistic.
So comes inventory of 30AC-130J aircraft
that comes in at 165 million each.
So that's more than an F-22,
that's more than an F-35.
And this is an aircraft
that can only fly in
permissive environments.
It's typically only used at night
and is almost never used
in support of conventional units,
even in extremist.
Another example might be
the AT-802U light aircraft,
which is a modified crop duster
that SOCOM attempts to use
for close air support and armed overwatch.
And this program will
come in at$ 3 billion.
I mean, is that a
example of an acquisition
that's gonna make a lot of sense
in great power competition
in high intensity,
major theater war?
Not so sure about that.
I would say paradoxically,
although expected to conduct operations
with the highest levels of
discipline and discretion,
in fact, a disproportionate number
of the most egregious mishaps
in the war on terror befell SOF units.
And I'm not gonna give
you a long laundry list,
although I have one if you're interested.
But if you picked a military disaster
from 2001 up to about 2018 or so,
there's about an 80% chance
that it involved the SOF unit,
not a conventional unit.
And I think that calls for some inquiry
into why that might be.
In fact, there was an inquiry
that was commissioned
by General Clark in 2019
after some congressional pressure,
which resulted in some findings,
which I thought were interesting.
But not sure if it got
to the bottom of that.
It may well be,
and you all might know better than me,
it may have something to do with OPTEMPO.
We can have a conversation about that.
It may have something
to do with the explosion
and size of the force.
It may have something to
do with the connectivity
or lack of connectivity
with battlespace owners.
There's a lot to unpack there.
But I think this is significant.
I think a major contributing factor
to what we're talking about
here is the strong tendency
to wall off
or to stove pipe Special
Operations Forces.
So I'm gonna throw a thesis
out on the table here,
which I believe is sort of an iron law
of bureaucratic politics,
which is that all organizations,
Boy Scouts of America,
First Presbyterian Church of Dothan,
or USSOCOM,
they all want two things.
They want the maximum amount of autonomy
and they want the maximum
amount of resources
that they could get.
Now, some organizations prosper
and are super effective at this,
Marine Corps is an example
that comes to mind,
and some are less successful.
I would venture to say
that the USSOCOM is
spectacularly successful at this.
So put yourself in the shoes
of General Petraeus in 2007 at MNF-I.
And the poor guy has got direct
control over Army forces,
but the Marines are not
task organized under him.
The Air Force is not
task organized under him
as a theater commander.
Black SOF is not task organized under him.
And white SOF is task organized
at the four star level,
which means for tactical actions
that are going on every single day,
there is no relationship there.
You can't monitor or manage
those at the four star level,
you just can't.
So if you're a battle space owner,
I'm sorry,
you're gonna have a lot of
SOF units running around
in your battle space.
And I can tell you this
from personal experience
as a unit commander
and five different campaigns.
And you're not gonna
know that they're there.
And maybe it's okay
and maybe it's not gonna be okay.
So that's a problem.
So if we believe that unity
of effort is important,
then I submit we need to strive
for true unity of effort,
which means let's get a line
synchronized, integrated,
and coordinated on the battlefield.
Let's not set up a huge wall
so that we can be as
autonomous as we want to be.
And I know I'm being provocative here,
but I think this is a conversation
that needs to take place.
H. R. McMaster has written at some length
about the rating strategy
that was carried out
by SOF forces all all
through the campaigns
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
which in a real way tended to work
against the rest of the theater strategy.
So if what we're trying
to do is protect the civilian population
and win the civilian
population over to our side,
which is a tentative of counterinsurgency,
then constantly traumatizing
the civilian population
with night raids,
some of which were successful,
but many of which were not,
tended to work at counter
purposes to the theater strategy.
It really did.
And I think this is something
that we need to learn from
and think about as we
project the role of SOF
into the next era,
which is gonna certainly
feature some elements
of going after violent
extremist organizations,
but is probably gonna have
a higher priority of trying
to posture to be effective
and to contribute to our success
in high intensity major theater war.
So I think these are some of the things
that we need to think about
as we look into the near term,
into the midterm.
I'd mentioned one other point in passing,
which I do think is important
and which I would call your attention to,
which is when you have an explosion
of SOF the way that we had
in the last 20 years or so,
it can only come at the expense
of the leadership cadre
of our conventional units.
So by skimming the cream
off the conventional units,
there is a cost.
I submit to you pretty high cost.
Army special forces
or the Army's SOF
community probably counts
for something on the order of
5,000 non-commission officers,
many of whom are at that
critical E-6 and E-7 level
that are deposited now
in the SOF community
and can't be leading soldiers
in the conventional force.
That's a really big number.
That's enough NCOs really to
cadre about an Army Corps.
So I guess the relevant question here is,
is the return on that investment better
by putting them in the SOF community?
Or would the return on
that investment be better
by leading soldiers in the
conventional community?
I think that's an interesting question.
A quick vignette,
my son was a platoon leader
in the 82nd Airborne Division the day
that Qasem Soleimani was killed.
His battalion was on DEER F1.
So no notice they blew out
to Iraq to secure the embassy
with none of its E-6
squad leaders authorized.
They had all departed for the Q Course.
And he was the fourth platoon
leader in that platoon
in one calendar year.
And his previous three
lieutenants had all departed
for special forces or
their Ranger Regiment.
And this is in the 82nd Airborne Division
which, in theory, is
supposed to be maintained
at the highest level of manning
and readiness that we have.
So it's a tough problem to deal with.
As a battalion commander in the 82nd,
I lost 16 NCOs in one
calendar year to the Q Course.
That's a crippling blow.
And you don't really have a vote
as a commander about
when these folks leave,
when it's time for them
to go to the selection,
they go to selection.
And you don't really get
a vote in all of that.
So I'll leave it to others to say
if a price worth paying,
I just want a flag for you
that there is a cost or a price to be paid
in terms of pulling a
lot of quality leaders
out of the conventional force
as we repost for great power competition
and we move away from sort
of the COIN G-1 environment.
I'll close for that,
but look forward to your questions.
I hope there'll be some.
Thanks very much.
- [Peter] My guess is there might be.
Colonel Jewell,
since you are one of
the employees of SOCOM
as part of JSOU,
over to you.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Richard.
- You're very welcome.
- There's a lot in that.
And I'll address a little bit of it
after I give you a little pitch
from our perspective
at the Joint Special Operations University
and the center that I am the
director of has a long name,
and Peter got it right.
But we basically run the
long term research projects
for the university.
This goes to something
Secretary Logan said
and something you said, Richard,
about learning and how
to adapt to what we did.
So our long-term history projects are
social science research,
history in theory informed,
applied to current
problems in the command,
in the enterprise specifically.
We're aligned now with PACOM,
or sorry, SOCPAC,
and SOC-Q , SOC-F,
and SOCSOUTH on four of our key products.
One is serving directly to our commander
and his command teams
as they're looking at
how to transform SOCOM.
People when transform as the
mantra in the headquarters,
how to transform Special
Operations command
and the SOF enterprise
to contribute SOF-peculiar capabilities
to integrated deterrents
and compound security
competition to deter left of,
for example, China insists,
China invading Taiwan.
For example,
something changing in
Europe with our acute threat
even more troubling than it has occurred.
And how do we build the force?
And yes, build is what we're
talking about, Richard.
So that's a little opposite
of what your suggestions are there
to be able to contribute
those SOF-peculiar things
to integrated deterrents
with joint interagency, intergovernmental,
multinational and commercial partners.
And these research projects are the engine
of what President Wilson,
the JSOU president,
calls SOCOM's think do tank
because we don't do that
just to serve those
commands we're working with,
we do that to cycle education
and create knowledge back
into the education
of the combined joint SOF
professionals for life.
That's a sales pitch.
I'm still practicing it.
I've been in the job since January 1st.
But during that time,
we sat in on the SOCOM's
commander's decision
round tables,
looking at a journey
as he describes it to transform SOF,
transform both the way
we employ the forces,
pushing that more down to
the TSOCs and the commands
and how we manage the force as
a service-like organization.
That's a pretty big step
after the GWOT years.
One of the theories that
JSOU proposes is a history
and theory-based background
to look at this practice.
It's called the Four Ages of SOF.
I think Ben's book
doesn't use those terms,
but he landed on very
similar things in it.
So in the modern era of SOF,
not counting Special Operations,
unconventional warfare,
regular warfare that occurred
long before our civil war,
that occurred long before our revolution
that are worth studying in
places as that history in theory.
But we started about
the time of World War II
when we started bringing together SOF
as formations to apply in that context,
support conventional operations.
We weren't really doing
a lot before, a lot.
We were doing some with our
partners for British partners.
Then in the '60s in the Vietnam era,
we grew the force
to go along with more or
less conventional operations,
relatively low intensity,
which is a term I don't love,
but still the war in Vietnam.
And then after operation Eagle Claw was
a huge threshold moment
that we didn't foresee.
One of those tragedies,
one of those great tragedies.
Our conference room in JSOU
is named after Eagle Claw.
The changes that came
from law, from Congress,
not from the command that set in motion,
the creation of Special Operations command
that set in motion the creation
of the assistant secretary,
director of SO/LIC to go
forward in SOF-peculiar things.
It also included education.
Mr. Locker,
who is one of the champions of that,
who we talk with every now and then,
as I said,
that they didn't get the
education part right.
They did say we have a university,
but we didn't get to all
the things we think we need
to educate SOF professionals for life.
And some people, Dave's mind,
I think we are leaning towards
being more service-like.
That's Dave's opinion.
How much more secretary?
A lot of the people have
clearer visions on it.,
but that goes kind of counter
to what Richard was saying here.
I grew up in the conventional
army almost entirely
in the intelligence community.
And I watched a lot of
great talent move over
in the Special Operations community.
I just took that as a challenge
to develop the talent we have
and keep them enlisted to
what their core tasks are,
where they're different from SOF-peculiar.
So now we have another threshold moment.
Again, Eagle Claw,
9/11 was another one
that caused us to go predominantly
towards the CT functions
and towards crisis response,
which remains our no fail function in SOF
at the expense
of some of the other
other 12 functions we did.
And now at this threshold,
after the end of the GWOT wars,
we think to support integrated deterrents
to support integrated
deterrents in competition.
The pasture remains fertile
to grow in the areas of civil
affairs for internal defense,
countering weapons of mass destruction,
which SOF just actually
got the responsibility for
as recently as 2016,
even though it had been
one of our core activities
going back to the beginning.
And at JSOU,
we're trying to set the
education for SOF professionals
so that we can learn from the bad examples
and the good examples,
apply theory to it,
social science theory,
international relations theory,
apply technology,
technology to enable the way we learn.
In the conversation earlier
about machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
I was interested and I said,
"I got some things to say,
but that's not my expertise."
But one thing we're
doing with some of that
in JSAU is trying to empower our education
with geospatial tools informed
by current social media,
current news and classical theory,
geospatially accessible
at the unclassified level
for our professor, for
our students, for units.
Much like the old CIA handbooks,
when I first went to a foreign country
in the early '90s,
make one of those that's enriched
with current geospatial data.
That's part of one of our research.
It's alongside our research projects
because that information
is very difficult to find
in a unified space,
certainly on the unclassified level,
which is where we're working.
And there is one thing I wanted to get to
to kind of respond to Richard.
It's not a debate.
But again,
I'm a little army intel guy,
and I'm used to the three telling me
I'm wrong about the enemy,
and I'll say I've studied it for a while.
One, I don't know the answer to why
somebody reported the whole SOF formation
as the same as the headquartes.
I don't know.
that's not correct.
The other number was about correct.
and the money-
- It was the Secretary of
Defense who reported it.
- Okay.
- Not just somebody.
- Out of my realm
and I don't doubt the report.
We don't have 73,000 people in Tampa.
- I'm sure you don't.
- We do not.
They wouldn't even all fit
in the football stadium
where the bugs are right now.
And the money, again,
Mr. Nessen, and the AT&L,
and the technology world outside of me,
but the SOF-peculiar of some
of the weapon systems you
named is a different addition
to the force.
It's a different addition to deterrence,
integrated deterrence
to influence, I think.
I've asked myself in the times,
why don't we have the RMC130
and the conventional force?
I don't know.
But they do provide something
in a way of low visibility,
something in a way of unique
capacity that is SOF-peculiar.
And if SOCOM
and specifically if JSOU is educating
on something that is
not mostly SOF-peculiar,
then we're stepping on the
grounds of the services
or other folks.
And so we try to find what SOF-peculiar,
what's combined joint SOF-peculiar
in a GMC joint,
interagency, international,
or intergovernmental.
Darn it,
I always forget it.
The multinational and
commercial environment.
And those are partnerships that JSOU
as part of SOCOM has where we are,
as an organization,
unencumbered by the classified
work that SOCOM does.
President Wilson went
to Taiwan in December
to have a discussion
with the Taiwan National
Defense University,
that's not the exact name of it,
education-based,
which hadn't been done at that level.
That included tens of two and three star
Republic of China, military,
and Department of Foreign Affairs leaders,
talking about what they
educationally think
they need to be concerned
about the security of Taiwan.
Small contribution,
building a relationship
that is not to replace
what the military formations are doing.
But then we come back and talk about that.
In fact,
INDOPACOM had people
there and so did SOCPAC.
So that's part of what we're
trying to do to work between.
So I'm an employee at SOCOM.
I'm the guy that my president
looks at most of the time
to work with what our headquarters does
because before I came to this job,
I was in our headquarters
being a typical normal military
planner guy.
and try to translate
that back into research
for the education of SOF
professionals for life.
I think I've gone too long.
And I will stop.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm gonna turn to Colonel Collins
who's also a retired
Special Forces officer.
I just want to inject also
just into the conversation
as we move forward.
One of the premises of this discussion,
I think maybe we should
try and unpack a bit,
which is the GWOT is over,
and it's all about
great power competition.
And I'm reminded,
and you can tell me if I'm
wrong, Colonel Collins,
but at West Point,
the generation,
the McChrystal betrays Odierno generation,
the Vietnam War was almost
like a verboten subject,
and it was sort of put
in the rear view mirror.
And are we making some version
of the same mistake now?
Because obviously the
National Security Defense...
Well, the Trump National
Security Defense strategy,
the Biden, they're very similar.
They emphasize the same things.
But are we gonna make another
version of the same mistake,
which is by putting this
thing in the rear view mirror,
basically unprepared for
the next time something
like this comes up?
- Yeah, I mean I think
there's less of mistake
of that happening this time,
but I mean the DoD,
we love to swing that pendulum.
And if you wanna justify
a $700 billion budget,
you have to have a huge
enemy to justify that budget.
So you gotta have an enemy out there
to justify a massive budget.
So you have that.
And so, yeah,
talking about the swing to
the great power competition.
I think a few years ago,
SOCOM at times has kind of
had this identity crisis
of what's our role gonna be in this?
Are we gonna lose our budget shares?
We kind of switch to
great power competition,
which is kind of unfathomable to me
because you just have
to look at our history
or look at how they're employed,
and that's not a fear.
But I think there's a few reasons
why this fear was
probably why they had it.
I mean one is I've argued
with Mike Sheehan and Mark Mitchell
about why the office is called ASD SO/LIC
that get rid of low intensity
conflict from the title.
Names and titles matter,
means the rest of the services.
Anything that deal with
low intensity conflict,
they just push off to SOF
because that's where it belongs.
It belongs in this office that's not ours
when they have a role in it.
And then SOF is then also left wondering,
if we belong to Special
Operations low intensity conflict,
what's our role in
great power competition?
Because that maybe isn't our realm
when it's always been the realm.
So just fix the title of the office
and you'll fix some of these problems.
And the third thing is we all know,
it's not low intensity if
you're the one getting shot at.
That's pretty fricking high
intense when that's going on.
But I mean, titles matter
and I think that's one thing.
But in terms of the
great power competition,
I've always hated this name, too.
It's great power conflict.
If you think we're not at
conflict with Russia and China,
you're wrong.
Ask them.
Ask Chinese and ask the Russians.
We are at conflict, right?
The problem is we have this
very narrow binary definition
of war and not war
and that's not how they view the world.
And when we view it from that perspective,
we're always gonna be a disadvantage
for this great power competition.
So I hate that word.
But again,
it's unfathomable
to me that like SOF
would sometimes question
what our role is in this.
When we've always had a role,
we're gonna be employed, right?
As Erin said earlier,
massive rule in this.
But I think part of the
problem is the coming out
of the GWOT in 20 years of this,
so that's 20 years.
So you have an entire
generation of officers.
That's all they know, right?
And during this,
I will agree with some of
the points Richard made
and I'll disagree with others,
but part of it was there
was way too much SOF doing
direct action during the conflict, right?
Maybe the COs should be doing it,
Rangers should be doing it,
select elements of SOF doing it.
But too many times,
special forces elements
were doing direct action
when they should be building
a host nation force.
And that was not helpful.
I remember (indistinct) in 2004,
talking to ODB commanders,
so an SF company commander that
had six detachments in Iraq.
And he was being directed to
do foreign internal defense.
And he said, "No, I don't wanna do that.
We wanna go do targets."
I'm like, "As opposed to
developing a 350-man battalion
and then you'd have
all these intel assets,
for them to hit targets,
they could hit so many
more than you could hit."
But part of the problem is
that's what SOF attracts.
SOF attracts a bunch of people
that wanna do direct action
and that is not the primary role of SOF.
for a small number of SOF forces,
that's it.
You're talking National
Mission Force, Rangers,
and the Army.
That's the main thing
not special forces,
but that's who they attract.
And then you wonder why
you have this dissonance
between what they want to do
and what they're gonna do.
To hit up on some of the
thing Richard talked about.
I'm not sure.
I don't doubt that was the case
in his environment about the black SOF
or white SOF running around
and not being coordinated.
I can just tell you everywhere I operated,
that was never a problem.
Before I did any raid,
I talked to the owning force
on the ground about it.
After we got done,
I talked to them.
And that was whether it
was with General Odierno
on down to lower level or General Mattis.
I remember a time
when General McChrystal's
building all the liaison networks,
expending them everywhere,
and he came to visit
General Mattis and he says,
"I don't need a liaison officer,
I got Liam here."
But he was right,
he needed a liaison officer
'cause I'm working full-time.
I can't spend all my time at the division,
but I disagree with that.
We had unity of effort
everywhere I was at,
even if we didn't have unity of command.
They're gonna be different
and that's the problem.
that's gotta be addressed,
but I don't think that's the solution.
And the owning forces,
it was never a problem.
I remember another,
Fourth Infantry Division,
they had a brigade operations
officer called me up one time
and said, "Hey, do you know
anything about this target?
It was white SEALs who
were hitting the target,"
and I said, "Nope.
Just tell them not.
Did they tell you why they're hitting it?
Or who it is?"
And they said no.
I said, "Tell them they can't hit it.
You own the terrain.
They can't hit it if you
tell them not to hit it."
I'm like, "I tell you every
single target I'm gonna hit
because for all I know,
you have a relationship with them,
I don't even need to hit the target
'cause you can go out
and get them for me."
And so I disagree with
that to some extent.
The talent problem of the talent drain
that you were talking about, Richard,
I mean I think that's not a problem
of SOF stealing people.
I think it's a problem
with the conventional army
that people wouldn't be
leaving it more than likely
in terms of why are they going to SOF
because it's not being handled right.
They aren't seeing satisfaction
in conventional army.
And the Ranger Regiment actually
is a benefit to the army.
They don't go there and stay there.
They go out there to Ranger Regiment,
and they come right back
after doing time there
and take those skills.
So I would disagree about
those forces stealing talent
from the service.
I think the problem's probably more
with the service level than anything else.
Yeah, I mean budget,
yeah, I would agree right there.
We have an insatiable,
I mean amazing ability
to grow and spend money.
I'm a little concerned not with SOF growth
because there's plenty of missions there.
We'll never have the missions that we...
We'll always have more missions
than we can ever execute again.
Why should we ever have
an identity crisis?
Never, right?
There's more things we can
do than we will ever do
and things that we should be doing.
We're always gonna be short of people.
My greatest fear with the
growth is we were never
at a hundred percent before
we added 4th Battalions,
we were never at a hundred percent
before we added Squadrons.
How the heck can you add,
grow when you've never had...
You just have so many talented
operators or analysts,
or whatever it is to put in these places.
That's the bigger problem to me.
The people are the most important thing.
And and I always joke,
it wasn't a joke,
but what's supposed to
be a 12-person detachment
and you go from 9 to 10,
but that 10th person is a negative.
You've grown from nine to eight
because you've gotta have
somebody watch this person
that can cause massive
strategic harm to your nation
by these people out there
as I think Richard kind of
pointed out some of those things.
The last thing I'll say in in terms of...
We shouldn't insert.
I'll talk about the forgotten
SOF forces here briefly<
civil affairs and PSYOPs
that we never talk about,
but they're part of it, too.
We should not send forces somewhere
without actually having a way
to actually measure their performance.
And you can do it.
Too often, we measure
measures of performance,
not measures of effectiveness.
And there's ways to do this, right?
Survey data,
other ways to do it.
But was doing a project
for one of the civil affairs groups
'cause they had multiple
ailments out there in Europe,
all doing kind of similar things
for different purposes all over Europe.
And I said, "Well, how do you
know if you're effective?"
He's like, "I have no idea.
That's why I'm coming to you
and have the cadets look at this project.
Are we actually being effective?"
And so figuring that out, like,
they're a small asset.
Let's figure out where
we can employ this asset
so we can get the most
return on the investment.
And so you gotta think
about how do you actually
measure that going in.
And if we can't measure it,
sometimes you...
I mean there's ways to get at it.
That should be part of the process.
When you're thinking
about deploying an asset,
how do we measure its
actual effectiveness?
What do we mean by effectiveness?
So that's kind of it.
But bottom line,
I mean SOF has a major role to play
in great power competition, right?
Building host nation capability,
access and placement,
building these relationships we can lever.
I mean, one of the best examples
and a success story during
the last 20 years is OEFPI,
the Philippines, right?
Very small preference.
Why did it work there?
Because no one in the US
military cared about it
'cause we were all in
Afghanistan and Iraq.
So you had a very small force
being very effective there.
And more often than not,
SOF is most effective
when we're actually forced to stay small,
like we did in El Salvador,
we did in Columbia.
Again, Columbia wasn't
effective from counter drug,
but effective from
counterinsurgency, right?
Philippines, right?
These are places.
And so one of the lessons is,
hey, we have to be artificially restricted
to be in small or we will grow too big
and you actually grow to be ineffective.
Thanks, Peter.
- Thank you, Ben.
- Oh what I forgot to mention,
he didn't mention that I'm
also a fellow with New America,
which Peter is the
president of New America.
- [Peter] Vice president,
but who cares?
So Ben, I have a terrible pun here.
You did the deepest of deep dives
on the history of the US Navy SEALs.
What are the lessons?
I don't know,
I'm only 150 pages in
and I thought it was absolutely brilliant.
One of the lessons I took away was
how many times certain
units were kind of created
for specific situations
and then sort of disbanded over time
as the rationale for their
existence seem to fade
or because of bureaucratic in fighting.
As you look forward to...
The pivot, obviously, is from the GWOT
to great power competition,
even if you don't necessarily agree,
that actually is the main...
Yeah, that's where the
defense establishment is.
Based on your sort of own
historical understanding
of all this,
how do you see this
playing out for the units
that grew up so spectacularly
in the war against terrorism?
- I don't know.
- Great answer.
- Make it up.
- You're right, right.
- Just make it up.
- Thank you, Peter.
Thanks for the question.
Thanks for my co-panelists.
And thanks for the invitation, Mike,
to be here.
This is my first panel
so this is a treat.
To catch everybody up
to speed on what Peter is talking about.
The early history of SOF
is in fact very choppy.
There's periods of stagnation, explosion,
merging of units together.
One of the thing
that Peter mentioned was
particularly the early creations
and disbandment of various units.
That happens lots of times.
So probably the best examples
of that are the Marine Corps Raiders
that are created in 1942.
They have some sort of
spectacular operations.
They're publicized in a very
popular movie at the time.
And a few weeks after the movie comes out,
they're disbanded.
Similar thing happens
with the Army Rangers.
Army Rangers are created in 1942.
Half of the Rangers are committed
to a disastrous raid in Italy.
They're disbanded.
The three other Ranger
battalions continue on
in World War II.
1945, no more Rangers,
Korean War comes along.
Army needs a sort of a
rating capability again.
They reestablished the Rangers.
Eight months after that,
Rangers are disbanded again.
They're not reestablished as a real force.
There's sort of Ranger type units
that are brought back in Vietnam.
But the Rangers,
as we know them,
are not really recreated until 1974.
So there is this period
of sort of creation,
disbandment, merging together.
And so I think the question
that we're all sort of
trying to understand
in this room is,
how do we move forward
into this new environment
where we have these new threats,
great power conflict as Liam said?
Well, I think it's interesting to know,
at least for that first
20, 30-year period of SOF,
we were always in great power conflict.
I mean, we've been in a new generation now
where we've had this
maybe incorrect perception
that we haven't been in
great power competition
because our conflict,
because we've been focusing
on insurgency groups,
low intensity conflict stuff.
But if we want to understand
why we are in the current situation
and how to project forward from that,
how we have C-130s,
why we have a colonel set
a potential talent drain
from the regular service branches,
why the ASD SO/LIC position
has that low intensity conflict
acronym at the end of it,
I think we have to
understand how we got here.
And one trick that you learn is
if you are a historian,
if you're going to write history,
is in order to understand why questions,
the first thing that you need
to do is understand what happened,
put things in order.
Why will always come to the surface
if you just start to put things in order.
And I think most of us have this idea
that special operation history
is the story of tension,
tension between conventional leaders
and unconventional leaders.
And that's true.
It absolutely is true.
There have been biases in the military
against elite troops
from the very beginning
of our history.
Most notably,
we start to see them in World War II.
You have leaders like Mark Clark,
even leaders like Eisenhower
and George Marshall
that are very, very reluctant
to create elite troops within the ranks.
One, because they don't want other troops
to feel like their
service is less important
than the elite troops,
but also for practical reasons.
They don't want the best
troops in their organizations
to flee and join those other more famous
or more whatever you wanna call it,
those other units.
So there's practicalities,
and those are absolutely all true.
Those all happen and
they're part of the story
and how we got here,
and they're part of that tension.
But it's also worth us remembering
that all of the unconventional units
that we have today were all
started by conventional leaders.
We have leaders throughout our history
that never served a day in anything,
you would even consider remotely special
or unconventional.
Emerald King, Kelly Turner,
John McGee, Bill Darby,
all of these guys,
they all came from conventional units.
So I think it's important
to really understand how
the real story happened.
We got here,
the tension that existed is, I think,
really was a result of partly
great power competition.
It was difficult in those early
years of Special Operations
to sort of figure out
where there was a place
for these sort of behind the lines Raiders
or behind the lines whatever.
When I was doing research for the book,
I sort of created a
little matrix for myself
to understand what a
Special Operations unit was.
With all the acronyms of things
that Special Operations Forces do,
I boiled it down into the,
I call the 3Rs of Special Operations:
recon, recking, and rating.
But in order to understand
what a special operation was,
I started to think
about like what defines
a special operation
'cause you could have an elite unit
or a special unit
that can be doing a conventional
operation or vice versa.
You can have a conventional unit
that's doing a special operation.
So what is a special operation?
So I started to think,
okay, well, it's usually
behind enemy lines.
And if it's not behind enemy lines,
it's at least beyond the
forward line of troop.
So if you're going to have a unit
that's going to be operating
in the forward line of
troops or behind enemy lines,
it's gonna have to move
at night at some point.
It's gonna have to get to its target
or wherever it's gonna
have to be done at night.
In order for that unit to move at night,
it's going to have to be small.
For a unit to move at night
effectively and quietly,
it's gotta be small.
And because it's small,
it has to be targeting a
target that's vulnerable.
So that little triangle
help me kind of understand.
So those three things,
if they got out of whack,
and it ceased to sort of
be a special operation.
Anyway, so how do we get this
institution that we have now?
And I think that's the biggest story
of American Special Operations.
We have this whole period
where all of these sort
of patchwork units are
operating independently.
But now, as Colonel
Hooker was describing it,
we've got this massive
industry of Special Operations
that it's protected from the top,
it's supported from the bottom.
It's how America does everything,
We take something small
and we build it up into
a major corporation.
And the fear now being,
well, are we more bureaucratic?
Probably.
Are we less able to
respond to current threats?
Possibly, yeah.
But there's a reason that
we have that bureaucracy
because there were all
of these other things
that sort of forced us to
create that bureaucracy.
So if we look at what happened in history,
I think we can get there.
Anyway, I could keep going,
but I'll stop for now.
- [Peter] Let me ask Colonel Collins
because you've just
came back from Ukraine.
I mean, obviously,
one of the big successes
in the Ukrainian war is Ukrainian SOF
and Major General Repass
has been part of that
who some people here may know.
And now, of course, the
training is sort of being cut,
done over FaceTime, essentially.
I mean, it's not in theater.
So why was that a success?
And what is the likely
outcome going forward
given the fact that it's not
hands on in the same way?
- Yeah, first, I'll answer.
I mean, I'll say it was a failure to deter
and I think we could have done it,
but there was no will in the US government
to actually do it.
So I'll spend a little bit of time on that
if that's okay.
Partly because there was no punishment
for Russia in 2008 following
their invasion of Georgia,
nothing in 2014,
2015 following their initial invasion
in illegal annexation into Ukraine.
We did have a $300 million
roughly year investment
that we were doing over there.
And I spent two years going back and forth
with General Abizaid
so I understand,
kind of saw the Ukrainians
evolve from 2016 to 2018.
One of the things we did,
and this was one of the mini signals is
we asked both the SHAPE commander
and we asked General Mattis
to put a general officer
in charge of the ground
of the effort in Ukraine.
We had a 2 to 300-man joint
military training group
train over there, training them.
Half a dozen ministry
defense advisors over there,
all these other kind of in and out things,
and $350 million dollar aid package.
You look at other places where
we've had this kind of thing.
Pakistan, when we needed
to go into Pakistan
and needed help from them,
we put Mike Nagata.
Israel, Saudi Arabia, some other places.
When you need it,
that's a signal, right?
And it's a signal to Russia,
you care about it.
But the answer was we don't
have a general to give
or admiral to give despite having 620
in the Department of Defense.
It meant we didn't care.
And we were communicating to Russia,
we cared.
So bottom line,
it was a failure to deter,
and we are where we're at today.
But yeah, the Ukrainians,
I mean one of the things,
everybody that we talked to over there
over a two-year period,
every single person said
they're not Iraqi or Afghani.
If you look at what can the US do?
What does the US not do?
Well, we don't build a
military on scale in a nation
where there's no political will to do it
and no one's good at that, right?
That's why it failed in
Afghanistan and Iraq.
And that's why it worked in Ukraine,
the political wolves behind it.
They're the ones that wanted to reform
and turn Western.
If you go to the panel later today,
you'll have somebody very critical of it.
But I'll cut it shorter on there,
but bottom line is the
SOF did a very good job
training there as they
basically stood it up
from scratch over there.
And because they're kind
of better at building it
than some of the other
commissional assets,
so have built a pretty effective.
And so, yeah,
what's really dependent
on Ukraine has continued western aid
to support the Ukrainians
because you've basically got a military
that's got the advantage
in every category except for mass.
Mass is the one category
Russia has the advantage,
and so they gotta kind of continue
to replace those weapon systems.
But yeah, they did a
good job of building it.
- Because I think on Iraq, I mean,
I would respectfully disagree,
I think that with the Iraqi
counterterrorism service,
it's one of the sort of
great unheralded successes.
- Niche force,
very good at building a niche force.
- Okay.
- We can't build a force on scale.
- Gotcha.
Okay.
Any questions?
(faintly speaking)
- [Eric] Eric Donio,
I'm an assault team leader
at Development Group.
I have a question.
Dr. Collins,
based on what you just said
about the efforts in Ukraine,
could you give some examples
of what is the Ukrainian
special forces are doing
that makes those operations
defined as special
kind of according to the three tenets
that Mr. Milligan spoke about?
A lot of the stuff we see in the news
and open source media seems like
it's mainly conventional warfare
that's taking place during the daytime.
Would you be able to give some examples?
- Yeah.
I mean, just think of the
defensive key, for example.
It's really hard to understand
the Ukrainian army coming in
with a Western perspective
or a US perspective
of how wars are fought.
It's kind of like our inherent
distrust with our government.
They kind of have that inherent...
The Ukrainian population
has this inherent distrust
with their military.
And so going back to 2014,
a massive number of volunteers went out
to the east to really defend
against the Russian-led separatist.
So they have this really weird construct
where you have this standing regular army,
but then you still have
these massive volunteers
from the defensive Kiev.
You would have civilians
basically running the drones,
establishing all the
named area of interest,
like looking out there,
talking right there with commanders.
So where was this some of their
special forces role in this?
Most of their force,
they really thought the
attack was gonna come here.
So they're really left with
a 72nd mechanized brigade
kind of defending capitol.
And they're really kind
of just at the edge
of the city limits as far as they went.
Pretty much everything forward
to that was just
civilians carrying weapons
and kind of step out there
kind of working with them,
I mean, as an example, right?
And so they're working with those guys,
or they might have the RPG or an in-law,
and then they're kind of
working with the ambush
as they approach to the
conventional forces.
So just kind of strange in that way.
I don't think they've had
as much success really
to kind of build in
that resistance network.
And I think there's a couple reasons
why I don't wanna get too much in Ukraine.
We're gonna hit it later.
We got a separate panel for it.
Because one is a lot of
Ukrainians are just leaving.
When the war comes to you,
you get the hell out of there.
I mean, most people leave cities
and the ones that are left.
So I think you haven't seen as
much resistance as you could.
And part of it was that
those resistance network
to be most effective had
to be set up in advance,
and they weren't set up in advance.
I mean, I did a video teleconference
with kind of the forces
responsible for defending Kiev
and this commander is basically,
three weeks before the war started,
no one believed that the
Russians were gonna invade
so they really weren't prepared for it
from that perspective.
And then I think they're
doing some deep raids, too.
But yeah, I mean,
it's a weird construct the way they're...
You would never have a
civilian come to the bunker
on the second day of the war
and come up with a plan to blow a dam
and then just say,
"Go.
Here, we'll give an engineer,
go to the ammo supply point.
Pick up a ton of TNT or dynamite
and blow the dam."
It's just unheard of.
- [Peter] In the absence
of other questions,
do you have a question?
Yeah.
- [Will] Sure.
- [Peter] Yeah.
- [Will] Yeah.
Hi, Will Myers,
I'm an assault team leader
over at Gabled Stone.
For Colonel Hooker and Dr. Collins,
you kind of got on this as well.
How do you resolve the
conflict in your mind
if Special Operations
is a drain on the talent
of the conventional force?
How do you resolve the issue of the fact
that if you're a conventional guy,
it's not like you're gonna
stay in the conventional army
if you don't go to SOF,
maybe you just get out of the army?
As we talk about it being a drain,
maybe it's just an opportunity.
someone like myself,
I've been in the army 16 years,
I wouldn't have been in the army 16 years
if I had to stay conventional.
Colonel, how do you address that?
- Well, if you break that down,
I think what you're really
saying is all these guys
that migrate to the SOF community
are either gonna migrate
to the SOF community
or they're gonna get out.
There's just no social
science behind that.
There's no data behind that.
That's all anecdotal stuff.
The E-6 that go to selection
and don't make selection
typically don't all get out
of the army
because they've got 10 years, 8 years,
11 years invested.
They're looking at
retirement down the road.
So the community is very large.
There's gonna be a suction pump effect
that's gonna draw talented
or quality leaders
into that side of the force.
The question that we need to be asking
at sort of the policy and
the strategy level is,
is that where these folks
make the biggest contribution?
At the end of the day,
you don't win wars with commandos,
you just don't.
You'll win them probably
with heavy divisions
and where their power.
Now, as I said it in my
very opening remarks,
there's a key role for SOF
to play in the national security toolbox.
No doubt about that.
But my critique is that
we've become unbalanced.
That's all.
I'm just trying to promote this idea
that we need to sort of rebalance.
Let's get back into the joint game.
Let's put all the tools under
the joint force commander
and stop taking tools away
from the joint force commander
so that we can integrate and
coordinate and synchronize
and get better effects on the battlefield.
Okay.
The community's been fighting
against that for a long time.
We need to get back,
I think, to first principles
and we'll be just fine.
- [Peter] Colonel Hooker,
you also quick sort of follow up,
which is there may not be
72,000 people in Tampa,
but there's certainly at least 60,000.
And most of them are civilians, right?
- 6,000.
- [Peter] 6,000, okay.
I mean, are there too
many civilians in SOCOM?
- Well, I don't think I'm
qualified to answer that,
but I can tell you how many there are.
Of that 6,194,
there are 2,000 civilians.
So maybe, I don't know,
you tell me.
it's a lot of civilians.
- I'll just jump in.
I mean, Richard,
you talked about data.
I'd like to see the data
because with as many 18x rays
that special forces that come
right in from the street,
as many of them that come into the force,
I find it hard to believe
there's more NCOs going to SF now
than there were 10 or 20 years ago.
I don't see that that it's possible
with the number perspective.
- [Audience 1] If I could just interject
a couple of data points,
and I apologize I didn't
bring these specific numbers,
but I can tell you that
we have collected data.
And the significant majority of folks
who go through selection
and do not make it actually
do have a track record
of going back to the regular forces
and becoming some of the longest serving
and most senior members of the NCO corps.
So we do have data that, I think,
shows almost the reverse,
that we become pillars,
sort of important pillars
for the regular conventional force
for those who don't end up making it.
Not as many actually leave entirely,
but they actually stay in at a higher rate
and stay in for longer careers.
I'll also point out that I
think the better comparison
for the headquarters numbers
in Tampa is if you look at what it takes
for the Army, Navy, Air Force, or Marines,
the military service side,
because that headquarters is
both a military service side
and AGCC operational side.
There are two hats that are worn
by that commander that is very unique,
similar to the role that
actually Secretary Mayer,
ASD SO/LIC wears
as a operational policy
advisor for the secretary,
as well as a service secretary like role.
And so it is a little bit complicated
to unpack those specifics.
But I do think that some of the questions
that, Colonel Hooker, that you
raised are really good ones
for us to reflect on
because I think for us
to meet the challenge we set ourselves
and continue to be better,
we have to question our
underlying assumptions.
And I think it's always fair
to say what more can we do better?
And are we giving the nation
the return on investment?
And I do believe that we
are rebalancing the force
to be more effective in competition spaces
and to effectively help pathfind
for the joint force in
certain ways in this space.
And I think that's an important role
that we like to play as pathfinders,
but keeping that balanced with not failing
in our No-Fail Missions,
including those for CVO,
I think, is really important.
Like I said,
it's not a debate,
but I did wanna set the record straight
that we do have some data about the impact
on the conventional forces.
And that's actually a little
bit counterintuitive, I think.
Thanks.
- [Michelle] Good morning, everyone.
Thank you for being panelists today.
My name's Michelle Poe.
I am in the army under USASOC.
I've been in for 18 years,
and I'm a member of the PRK cohort.
One class that we've been taking
this semester is rethinking
Special Operations,
and we've been examining how
SOCOM has 70,000 personnel
across the globe to
conduct global operations
and how certain elements of it are bloated
and have too many people.
And Colonel Hooker, as you
stated during your brief,
basically once 9/11 kicked off,
there was an ever-expanding number
of elements being added to
Special Operations Forces.
Now, that CT is winding
down after 20 years,
and it may be time
to start cutting away
those certain elements.
One thing we've been
talking about in class is,
is the government prepared to
cut down Special Operations
to kind of direct it from the top-down?
And how in an environment
where we are not used to saying no
or used to essentially saying, I'm sorry,
but these hundred people
have to go back to the army,
how do we do that?
Is there any ideas from the panelists?
- Well, you might have thought
that as the GWOT began to wind down,
and that really wasn't something
that happened in 2020,
that happened in like 2014 or so,
you might have expected
that just as the conventional force began
to decline in size,
so too with the SOF community.
In fact, that has not been the case.
So the additions that were made
at the height of the GWOT
remain in place today.
And year by year,
the requests are actually more
for augmentation than for reduction.
So I would suggest that one of the reasons
that the SOCOM staff
is, as large as it is,
is not to make it more rapid,
and agile, and responsive,
but to make it better able to contend
and compete in this competition
for resources inside the beltway,
which it does very, very effectively.
I mean,
it's true that SOCOM has
some service-like functions,
that's undeniable,
but the Army staff is
tasked with looking after
when you include the reserve component,
almost 10 times as many people,
more than 10 times as many people.
So the idea that both staff
should be the same size seems
to me is problematic.
I don't expect to see a sharp reduction
in the size of special forces,
although I think it's...
I mean, one of your foundational
strategic documents makes the point
over and over and over again
that quality is more
important than quantity.
I think it's unarguable
that if you get twice as big,
you're not gonna be able
to maintain the same level
of quality as you had before.
I just think that's unarguable
and may contribute to
some of the bad things
and disasters that we saw happened
over the last 10 or 15 years.
I don't think you're gonna get a lot
of senior people agreeing with that,
at least not publicly.
But I think it's something
that's certainly true.
And I don't expect a SOF
community to decline in size.
I mean, I just don't
think it's a kind of issue
that rises to the level of
the president's attention.
And I think it would take
presidential intervention
for something like that to happen.
- State of your name.
- [Jackie] Thanks, everyone.
I'm Jackie Deal
from long-term strategy
group in Washington D.C.
And I was wondering
if you guys could speak a little bit
to how well we're doing
or how well either the joint force
or the SOF community is doing
at understanding the PRC
and the Chinese Communist Party
as a competitor or as a opponent.
It took a while, I think,
for us to get up to
speed on terror networks
and the radical Islamist threat.
How would you say we're doing
on understanding our peer foe today?
- I'll take a jump at this.
And this is from both me as the researcher
and as an old intel guy.
I think we're doing
about as well as we can
as part of the research.
Chinese military
and educational
institutions publish a lot.
They publish a lot.
They publish a lot unclassified.
We have pretty good intelligence access
to a lot of the other communications
at a lot of levels.
It stops at the top
tier of the CCP, though.
So what is the PLA
or the PLA Navy likely to
do in a certain situation?
I think we have SOF perspective
and I think joint force perspective,
a fairly good idea.
But what's gonna happen with G
and his six or seven
closer ones, we don't.
That's Dave's opinion.
Watch him really closely trying
to answer our commander's question.
How do we get G to say
not today to go to Taiwan?
So there's a gap there.
- Isn't that gap just maybe
baked into the situation,
which is himself may not
know what he wants to do?
- Absolutely.
As an old S2 in the army,
one time the armored
battalion commander asked me,
"How come you can't tell me
what the enemy infantry
battalions are gonna do
at NTC in two days?
I said, "Well, here's your
armored battalion commander,
your buddy, you live next door to him.
What's he gonna do in two days?"
And he doesn't know.
So yes, that is part of it.
And also ESG is very powerful
and very well-protected
and has, by their law,
pretty much absolute control.
I feel we know more about it
than we did about the
inner workings of ISIS
when they started rising.
I think we know more about it
than we did about the
inner workings Al-Qaeda
shortly after 9/11
because they write a lot.
- One final comment from Dazi Logan.
- [Dazi] Sorry, I don't wanna cut short
that discussion on PRC
and our understanding,
but I did wanna say,
I think the other thing
that it's important to keep in mind,
again, I think that I don't think
that we've grown too large
in SOF as we've shifted
and I think the rules that we are playing
and continue to play,
but part of that comes down
to a very basic fact,
which is our most senior
national leaders keep turning
to SOF.
They keep asking SOF to do the missions.
So if the president keeps
asking us to do these missions,
we are using our force fully today.
They are fully occupied.
There's nobody sitting around
just thinking great thoughts
except maybe the few of you
in this room (indistinct).
But in general,
the vast majority of our
forces is fully employed.
And they keep being regularly employed
for a spectrum of things that, arguably,
in some cases,
you could have conventional forces doing,
but the senior leadership
of this country doesn't appear willing
to take that chance for whatever reason.
And so I think that is
the fundamental factor
that there are a lot of people
who have raised the questions
that Colonel Hooker has is,
have we grown too large?
Can we maintain the quality?
The flip side of that
is I think using a lot
of what we've learned
over the last 20 years,
we actually think that our assessment
and selection process
have gotten much better.
And so in some ways,
our ability to maintain
quality has improved
even as we have grown.
And that is a little
bit of a counterbalance,
but there clearly is a limit.
And I think that's where we ask ourselves,
are we being used in the missions
that give the biggest return, again,
on investment for the nation?
Because where we are
and arguably there are certain
places we would love to grow.
We actually can't really
grow very effectively.
I think there is a real limitation there
that you identify.
I don't think we hit it today,
but I think we're very close.
And so that actually becomes a frustration
as national leaders ask us to do even more
in certain spaces where we
haven't been able to grow.
- Thanks to our well-informed
and lively panel.
(audience applauding)